on wednesday night the u.s ambassador to
russia john sullivan hand-delivered the
american response to russia's demands
for increased security guarantees amid
its standoff with the west over ukraine
the letter several pages long repeats
the biden administration's position
u.s troops go where they're wanted
individual countries decide whether they
want to join nato
and russia must abandon any plans to
invade ukraine moscow says it has no
such plans
the
document is with them and
the ball is in their court we'll see
what we do as i've said repeatedly
whether they choose the path of
diplomacy and dialogue whether they
decide to renew aggression against
ukraine we're prepared either way good
to see you again but the u.s also
offered some proposals it thinks could
reassure russian president vladimir
putin and his government
renewed arms control deals improved
transparency on u.s engagement in
ukraine
and changes to u.s nato exercises in
eastern europe
the russians received a similar note
from nato leadership in a bid to head
off possible conflict in ukraine we call
on russia once again to immediately
de-escalate the situation
nato firmly believes that tensions and
disagreements must be resolved through
dialogue and diplomacy
nato is offering to host negotiations
between the u.s and russia to resolve
the crisis but stoltenberg told
reporters 5 000 nato rapid response
troops can be called up in just a few
days if needed
but washington and its european allies
have stepped up deliveries of military
aid to kiev including defensive weapons
unity among western nations though has
not been complete germany notably hasn't
provided any military aid to kiev
ostensibly because of its reliance on
oil and gas deliveries from russia the
u.s reportedly is trying to address
those concerns
i'm absolutely confident in german
solidarity in being with
together with us and other allies and
partners in confronting renewed russian
aggression against ukraine meantime the
u.s and russia are still locked in a
spat over diplomatic visas
26 russian diplomats and their families
left washington on wednesday because of
what the russian ambassador called
ongoing harassment by american
authorities u.s officials say it's now
up to moscow to respond to what the
americans consider reasonable proposals
to end the crisis but they say they're
still ready to impose the harshest
sanctions possible if moscow orders its
troops to invade ukraine rosalyn jordan
al jazeera the state department